on va passer maintenant hors auto et ça
c'est une bonne idée je pense ou n'est
ce que l'on pensait le retour d'internât
[Musique]
alors c'est nani qui l'annoncé donc
mercredi sur twitter et j'ai l'épisode
va devancer qu'en 2020 ce sera le retour
d' intervilles que j'aurai la chance de
produire sur france 2 avec les bonnes
âmes recommande valérie bègue bruno
guillon et olivier minne déjà très beau
trio il ne présente pas je ne présente
pas les produits ne présentent pas
beaucoup parlé des klaxons avec un bon
pour ça je vraiment pas mais il est vrai
que c'est un jeu et a fait des années et
des années et des années que tout le
monde veut reprendre ce jeu ça arrive
enfin alors est-ce qu'on a un peu les
coulisses de cette négociation pourquoi
et comment c'est arrivé
oui oui il ya plein d'éléments de
d'abord il y aura peut-être vache est
donc ça c'est l'élément fondamental du
changement d'intervilles qui avait connu
par top aux vachettes
c'était quand même la base avec toutes
les polémiques que ça peut générer donc
le plus d'animaux sauvages dans
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il y avait martine martine à la ferme
avec des chevaux sauvages y avait des
poules
il y avait des chèvres et des cochons
j'étais super dangereux concerne les
fondamentaux des villes qui bataillent
ensemble on et jeux d'eau des jeux
acrobatiques et parfois un peu physique
à mercy est bien commode voilà mon jeu
lancé en 62 par lg luxe on sait bien
c'était un énorme carton moi pour le
coup alors et dieu sait pourtant très
jeune mais c'est tout pendant sa
télévision
oui le formidable simone garnier et sa
génération alors l'a dit claude savary
ou et les oreilles c'est pas terrible et
longtemps et très longtemps c'est le
rêve de nagui de remettre interdit à
l'antenne il avait déjà remis en 2013 ça
est fait à peu près 20% d'audience
le problème de ce programme qui coûtait
très cher vous savez c'était deux
régions qui savent bien faire et à un
moment donné il y avait un problème
économique à faire ce genre le programme
promettant qu'il y en a trois ou quatre
qui sont prévus précédemment
deluxe mais moi ma génération c'est les
années 90 avec jean pierre foucault
fabrice julien courbet et olivier
chiabodo à huy s'était présentée par
nathalie simon tex et et rappelle les
mines d'ebolowa
c'est vrai et c'est moi qui avais une
question est-ce qu'on a des images bien
sûr on a toujours des images on va me
dire non dans l'animal examen quand même
une petite réaction comment vous pouvez
dire que ce trio est des magistrats il
est absolument je vous dis qu ils m ont
dorénavant j'ai eu des simples lumière
et tout ce qui vient de france 2 je
trouve ça génial génialissime même est
sorti du cerveau d'un génie oui mais
bruno guillon quel rapport entre les
amis
bien son métier très bien son métier
non mais arrêtez si vous dites n'importe
quoi je me bats alors olivier millet
excellence gallery bègles gelé lancer
dans l'animation victoire ou de la
fortune que je présente et oui on en
vient à manquer les cinq jours après le
méro avant d'être une jolie sont
d'accord si maryse et moi mais c'est
vrai que quand on dit c'est super ce
contrat me reviennent mais bon on aurait
pu être un petit peu plus audacieux et
trouver autre chose et je reviens sur ce
que vient de dire gilles pardon mais le
casting on aurait pu lire d'olivier
minne mètres 1-2 chavanne et surtout une
francesca par exemple qui à la fois de
la répartie d'humour et de l'énergie il
va être content nous n'avions à chaque
fois nous avons marche sur fun radio la
matinale fonctionne de façon un petit
peu les jeunes on sait la vachette métro
avait coûté polémique avec les arrivées
sur les plateaux comment il va
tu
[Applaudissements]